en este vídeo vamos a aprender cómo
racionalizar el denominador y
racionalizar racionalizar el denominador
y lo que quiere decir esto es supongamos
que tenemos una fracción cuyo
denominador no es un número racional la
más simple en la que puedo pensar es uno
sobre raíz de dos entonces para
racionalizar este denominador tenemos
que representar este número de alguna
manera que no contenga un número
racional en el denominador y lo primero
que podrías cuestionar es sal porque
necesitamos hacer eso porque debemos
racionalizar denominadores y no es que
tengas que racionalizar los pero yo
pienso que la razón por la cual en
muchas clases de álgebra muchos maestros
quieren hacer eso es para transformar
los números en un formato común también
podemos considerar como me han dicho en
las remotas épocas en que no había
calculadora para ciertas operaciones la
gente encontraba más fácil hacerlas si
había un número racional en el
denominador yo no sé si eso es verdad o
no quizá también la otras razones por
estética o alguien podría decir no tengo
ni idea de lo que es uno sobre raíz de
dos no tengo ni idea de qué tan grande
es esa magnitud prefiero
racional en el denominador habiendo
dicho eso aprendamos cómo racionalizar
denominadores la manera más simple
hacerlo es si el denominador consiste en
un simple irracional como éste tan solo
multiplicas el numerador y el
denominador por el número irracional
dividido sobre el mismo número
irracional ahora esto claramente es uno
recordemos que cualquier número dividido
sobre sí mismo siempre es 1 por lo que
no estamos modificando el número
simplemente estamos cambiando la manera
de representarlo y esto que es igual el
numerador es uno por raíz de 2 lo cual
es igual a raíz de 2 y el denominador es
raíz de dos por raíz de 2 bueno raíz de
dos por raíz de 2 esto es igual a 2 por
definición este número elevado al
cuadrado es igual a 2 y lo estamos
elevando al cuadrado lo estamos
multiplicando por sí mismo por lo cual
es igual a 2 hemos racionalizado el
denominador quitamos la raíz del
denominador pero le hemos llevado al
numerador ahora él denominó es un número
racional un numero racional y ahora
puedes decir oye ya tengo un número que
es raíz de dos medios
un número mucho más fácil de nombrar lo
cual quizás es otra buena razón para
racionalizar el denominador hagamos
algunos ejemplos más digamos que tenemos
7 sobre raíz cuadrada de 15 lo primero
que voy a hacer voy a tratar de
simplificar raíz cuadrada de 15 15 es 5
por 3 ninguno de ellos es cuado perfecto
entonces creo que ya tenemos esto
reducido a su mínima expresión y así
como hicimos aquí vamos a multiplicar
esta expresión por raíz de 15 sobre raíz
de 15
esto es igual a 7 por raíz de 15 es 7
raíz de 15 simplemente multiplicamos los
numeradores dividido entre raíz de 15
por raíz de 15 raíz de 15 por raíz de 15
es 15 de nueva cuenta hemos
racionalizado el denominador esto es
ahora un número racional
básicamente pasamos el radical al
numerador el cual es ahora un número
irracional no hemos cambiado el número
simplemente cambiamos la manera de
representar lo sumamos un poco de nivel
qué pasa si tenemos algo ligeramente más
complejo por ejemplo 12 sobre
2 - raíz de 5 en este caso lo que
tenemos es un binomio el denominador y
este binomio contiene un número racional
aquí no puede usar el mismo truco si
multiplico esto por raíz de 50 raíz de 5
voy a obtener un número irracional en el
denominador deja demostrártelo para que
veas que no funciona multiplicamos por
raíz de 50 raíz de 5 y que obtenemos en
el numerador es 12 por raíz de 5
mientras que el denominador es para
distribuir esto es 2 por raíz de 5 -
raíz de 5 por raíz de 5 es igual a 5
como puedes ver en este caso esto no
funcionó sigue presente la raíz de 5
aunque esta parte se hizo racional se
hizo 5 esta parte si su racional 2 raíz
de 5 así que esto no nos sirve de nada
cuando tienes el denominador un binomio
que contiene un número irracional lo que
usamos aquí es el conocimiento y la
habilidad para manejar una diferencia de
cuadrados
hagamos una pequeña nota por aquí lo que
aprendimos hace tiempo y quizás no hace
tanto tiempo es que
- raíz de 5 x 2 + raíz de 5 esto que nos
da
quizás lo recuerdes pero si no puedes
reconocer el mismo patrón en el caso del
producto de a menos b por a más b a
menos b por a más de y esto es igual
como vimos en vídeos anteriores aa
cuadrada menos b cuadrada a ver leche
que nos aporta es igual a cuadrada
aporte es igual a a d
- b por a es igual a menos a b y
finalmente menos b por b es igual a
menos b cuadrada estos dos términos se
cancelan y obtenemos finalmente a
cuadrada menos b cuadrada entonces aquí
tenemos dos menos raíz de 5 por 2 más
raíz de 5 lo cual es igual
a el cuadrado de 2 que es igual a 4
déjame reescribir lo mejor de esta
manera va a ser igual a 2 al cuadrado
menos el cuadro de raíz de 5 que es
simplemente 5 así que esto es igual a 4
5 o menos 1 hemos aprovechado lo que
conocemos del producto de un binomio por
su conjugado o de factorizar la
diferencia de cuadrados de cualquier
manera que lo quieras ver este es el
método que vamos a utilizar para
racionalizar este denominador hagamos
eso déjame reescribir el problema esto
es 12 entre 2 - raíz de 5 y lo vamos a
multiplicar por 2 + raíz de 5 entre 2 +
raíz de 5 de nueva cuenta estamos
multiplicando el número por 1 por lo
cual no le estamos alterando simplemente
estamos cambiando la manera de
representarlo y esto va a ser igual a 12
por 26 24 más 12 por raíz de 5 es 12
raíz de 5
ese es el numerador sobre y por acá que
tenemos bueno de nueva cuenta estos son
los factores de una diferencia de cuadra
así que esto va a ser el cuadrado el
primero que es igual a 4 aquí lo vimos
va a ser igual a 4 menos uno perdón esto
es 4 menos 5 es aquí tenemos 2 al
cuadrado menos raíz de 5 al cuadrado es
4 5 esto es menos 1 o podemos escribir 1
en el denominador y ponemos el signo
menos antes de la fracción no es
necesario escribir el 1 del denominador
así es que esto es igual a menos 24
menos 12 raíz de 5 y de hecho no tan
solo racionalizamos sino que también
simplificamos bastante la expresión se
ve mucho mejor no sé si lo mencioné al
principio pero esto es bueno porque esto
no es tan obvio si tú y yo vamos a hacer
un cohete y supongamos que esta es tu
respuesta y estar acá es mi respuesta
bueno no es obvio a simple vista que
ambas son iguales pero si nos ponemos de
acuerdo en siempre racionalizar nuestro
denominador es fabuloso vamos a obtener
siempre el mismo número estamos listos
para mandar nuestro cuente a marte
hagamos otro como estos
vamos a hacer otro como estos acá abajo
y vamos ahora a hacer uno que incluya
variables
similar a estos pero que incluye
variables supongamos que tenemos 5 y
sobre
2 raíz de y menos
vamos a seguir exactamente el mismo
proceso tenemos un denominador que tiene
un binomio irracional bueno podría ser
un racional no sabemos realmente cuál es
el valor de y ya que puede tener
cualquier valor en algunos casos será
irracional lo que si no queremos es un
radical en el denominador entonces esto
que va a ser igual x 2 raíz cuadrada de
i + 5 sobre 2 raíz cuadrada de i + 5 y
este número insistimos es simplemente 1
no estamos modificando el número
simplemente lo estamos multiplicando por
1 y esto que va a ser igual empecemos
con el denominador el denominador va a
ser igual a esto al cuadrado de nueva
cuenta una diferencia de cuadrados va a
ser igual a 2 la raíz cuadrada de y
elevado al cuadrado menos 5 al cuadrado
si tú factorizar esto lo que se obtiene
es 2 raíz cuadrada de 5 por 2 raíz
cuadrada de y menos 5 es una diferencia
de cuadrados y el numerador va a ser 5
por 2 raíz cuadrada o simplemente sería
10 y está y un medio y este es a la
primera potencia
escribirlo como ya raíz de y es decir 10
g por la raíz cuadrada de lo cual
también podría escribir como ya la tres
medios oye al aumentar en un medio como
la vida es mejor para finalmente obtener
cinco y por cinco más 25 que y esto lo
puedo simplificar aún más nuestro
dominador va a ser igual a esto es 2
elevado al cuadrado lo cual es 4 la raíz
cuadrada de y elevado al cuadrado es y
esto es 4 qué
- 5 al cuadrado menos 25 y ahora para el
numerador que tenemos aquí que podemos
hacer con él podemos escribirlo
exactamente como lo tenemos aquí o
podríamos factorizar y hay varias cosas
que podemos hacer pero mantengamos las
cosas simples escribamos lo cómo está
esto es 10 déjame escribirlo diferente
puedes escribir esto como 10 porque a la
primera y este es llegar a un medio esto
lo puede escribir como que a la 3 medios
o también lo puede escribir como ye a la
un entero un medio si así lo quisiera o
podemos dejarlo como está 10 raíz
cuadrada de y todas estas son
equivalentes más 25 y en fin espero que
hayas encontrado la racionalización
denominador es interesante